o fair golfer I'd be Caddyshack for sure  hands down that's the one most guys on  tour probably talk about the most the  crowd is just on his feet you Bill  Murray is pretty classic in that movie  if you know we can pretty much quote any  line out there it looks like amoret good  to know it's in the hole it's in the  hole I'm sure each all right that's a  feat hon it's just classic and then  maybe happy go more and you've been  around golf courses you know some of the  characters a little bit extreme really  there's so many great lines in there and  so many great characters or you just  come home that's your home are you to  click for your home too good for your  home answer me answer me hello I like 10  cup I think it's a great story oh you  know the you know kind of the the last  hole where you send all the shots it's  just you know i like it i think gotta  get drunk get drunk okay you always play  better way to waste